walk into this video playing FM mock why
does not have a name in them but yet
only plays five minute I have a bad
score though lost 2-1 to 11 game okay
the Torah high-tech many ways to combat
that this is just one good line black
gets the bishop pair at some point I
will I will take but it's nothing that
needs to be done immediately black can
also host develop and try to ask right
okay we are going to put your king yeah
i'm most likely want to put it on the
same side ok so here probably long
castle there is nothing there's no big
argument against that I guess I can do
that yeah that will take on g3 soon i
also have a five though maybe I'm
getting this I can do that right I guess
so keeping this f4 idea in the position
or maybe e5 even could be nice I must be
cautious if I've there potentially
potentially is 95 as h5 is hanging so
this can be if can be an issue I don't
know I mean I can also suggest oops
what's this I have a overlooked
something I don't understand
what's happening here I can take here
first to avoid any sort of problem I
cannot take I don't understand that
really why what's the t-shirts issue
might be three I even have f4 I mean if
it's never good or is it I have f4
actually even here tags tags on e to be
should be too yeah it's not not like I'm
winning material here I also simply have
Queen f7 who does he get it back I
really don't get the move maybe he wants
to take the fish Knight a5 I already
don't understand them okay I just should
should play I take here or we take here
first I'm taking it first I'm covering
age five anyway and here I cannot play
c6 unfortunately sd-6 hangs was checked
so I must take here first and c6 and
black is just a born up a big center
pole
um c 5 c 5 9 95 a stupid Bishop d7 i
take c 3 answers there should be seven i
take d4 I mean and then C 3 this is not
playable at all yeah this is very nice
not and on light b5 I just go bishops in
6 and this is a very awkward pinning
situation isn't it here I take just I
just take here and then on c3 my bishop
on g7 will be monstrous yeah I don't
know do you find maybe this was just a
mouse slipping t5 it really looked
looked very strange yam chips III is
fine but taking taking with the rook
looks looks very very problematic okay
just stroke c8 or wind we never a rookie
form
hmm
yeah not quite sure what the best
continuation is
white resign you see one is made next
move I can just do this and queen bee to
check made the id-5 was was a real lemon
maybe it was mostly I don't know it
looks very strange to play that
deliberately I mean okay I like the
whole position for black it's just that
black has a space that I want to chill
on the kingside this Bishop is somewhat
in trouble can always be taken just for
the bishop pair for nothing and they
have the c5 idea of expanding in the
center well it's not so clear how wide
is doing anything with it spawns e4f for
just loses the bishop this is a strange
move as an egg still can I can just do
that it's not he's not getting it back
in any case yeah and I don't know this
looked okay to me yeah now c5 is just
winning right yeah it's just red wedding
minus 3 there is no no defense night be
5 a-6 is even stronger okay I didn't see
that I just thought that this would
would be great setting up this strange
pin where wide really like smooth okay
this was a very but i want to check one
thing though oopsie eight rooks is a
reeking be one rook c8 is somewhat
stronger okay it's not a big difference
it's not a big difference yeah actually
I was a bit slightly worried that rookie
forward would be still the defense but I
can go here here and look c5 this is
what i actually had thought just put
something here on the fifth-ranked it's
it's simply that you can never take
channels check their various checkmates
okay well thanks for watching